[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH GRISDALE: Thank you.
My name is-- again--
Josh Grisdale, and I
run Accessible Japan.
And it's a website that shares
the accessibility features
of living in Japan with people
who are interested in visiting
that have a disability.
I didn't grow up in
high Roppongi hills,
but instead, when I looked out
my window, this is what I saw.
And this is the view
from my bedroom.
I live in a small,
small town outside
of Toronto called Oxbridge.
And it was me, my sisters, my
parents, and about 20 sheep.
So that's what I spend
most of my time looking at.
Now, I have what's
called cerebral palsy.
And it's a very
fancy way of saying
that I have brain damage.
There's two ways to
describe brain damage.
And after your brain
has finished developing
and you maybe have an accident
or something like that,
then that would be a regular
type of brain damage.
Cerebral palsy happens when
your brain is still developing,
so when you're very young.
And because of that,
as you develop,
your body will
develop differently.
And it can have a wide variety.
For example, some
people can just
have a little bit of trouble
moving their arms around.
And other people can be
completely-- have to stay
in bed all the time.
I'm somewhat in the middle.
I'm classified as severe.
But for me, the way it affects
me is my arms and my legs.
So they're physically healthy,
but the signals from my brain
don't properly get conveyed
to move the muscles
the way I want.
And because it happened when I
was young, when I developed--
for example--
my hands, the muscles at the
bottom were always tight.
And so as I grew bigger,
because it was tight,
my hands started to bend down.
So when you look at
pictures when I was a kid,
my hands were much
more straight.
And so that's probably one
of the main differences
between regular brain
damage and cerebral palsy.
So what's that mean
for my daily life?
Well, I have to have somebody
that's called a helper,
and maybe in English, it
would be more commonly called
a personal care assistant.
So today, I'm here
with Hyashi San,
so I'm very thankful for
his assistance every day
of my life.
So what happens is people with
disabilities can get evaluated
by the city they're living in.
And they get a certain
number of hours
that they can use
in their daily life.
And then, you contract
with different companies
in your local area
and make schedules
for your daily routine.
So my helpers help me from the
first thing in the morning.
So the first person I see in
the morning and last person
I see at night is my helper.
And not so romantic, but--
[LAUGHING]
But yeah, so they help
me get up in the morning
and have a shower, get dressed,
et cetera, get ready for work.
And then after work, they help
me maybe with some shopping
or with cooking or
cleaning around the house.
And then at night, they
help me get into bed
and do it all
again the next day.
For when I go out, my daily
life requires a lot of planning,
planning ahead.
Not something I can just
jump on a train and go
meet somebody somewhere.
I need to think, for
example, if that night I
have a helper scheduled,
I have to be back
before the helper
comes, or else I'll have
to pay the cancellation
fee, or I may not
be able to get into bed.
When I think about
transportation,
I always have to
leave extra time.
Any transfer usually takes
about 20 minutes longer
than it says on Google Maps.
So I have to take those
things into account.
When I'm going out
with friends as well,
I need to think
about restaurants.
It can be a very big challenge
to find a place to eat.
It's a very simple
task for most people.
But for me, because of
my electric wheelchair,
it's very difficult to
get into many restaurants,
particularly in Japan where
they tend to be very small.
And I love Japan, but
I don't like genkan,
because it's a step
that keeps me out.
So it can be discouraging
at times trying to go out.
Maybe you want to eat ramen,
and so you're out with friends,
you want to go get ramen.
You find a lot of
delicious looking places,
but you can't get
into any of them.
And then you have to go
to a family restaurant
or something like that.
And so planning ahead
is very important
so you can figure out
what is available for you.
So with all those
extra requirements,
why would I come to Japan?
Well, it was talked
about earlier.
I took a class in
Japanese in high school,
and my Japanese teacher,
he really loved Japan.
And that was infectious.
And so I thought, oh,
I want to try going.
And my parents, they'd
always encouraged
me to follow my dreams.
They always said that even
though you have a disability,
you can do what other people
can do to a certain degree,
or as same as them.
It may just take a bit more
time or do things a little bit
differently.
But you should always
follow your dreams.
Now, they say they regret that,
because I've moved to Japan now
and never go home.
But by the first
time I came, there
was really little to no
information on accessibility
in Japan.
Now, Google was
around at that point.
But if there's to find, then
your search results are zero.
So through a lot of phone calls
and very, very vague books
and stuff, I decided
to take the risk,
and I came to Japan with my
dad for a couple of weeks
back in the year 2000.
And I was really surprised to
find how accessible Japan was.
It was different than my
expectations, I think.
And I realized that, hey,
this is a place I could live.
And so after
finishing university,
I decided I wanted to
come and move to Japan.
When I did that, there
was a real requirement
for a lot of logistics.
As I said, I need helpers.
In Canada, the government
provides the helpers,
and in Japan as
well, the government
provides the helpers.
But in the interim, I
needed to bring somebody
with me to take care of me until
I could get into the system.
So I had to come with someone
for about six months until I
was able to get
fully in, as well
as finding a place to live.
It can be very difficult
to find an apartment that's
accessible to wheelchair users.
So, again, a lot of planning
and overcoming logistics.
But I got here, and I've
been here for 10 years now.
And as mentioned, I became a
Japanese citizen last year.
And so I'm actually no
longer a Canadian citizen,
because I had to give
up my citizenship.
But here I am to stay for good,
whether you like it or not.
[CHUCKLING]
The company I work at right
now, it's called Azali Group.
And one of their core
principles is giving back
to society and your
local community.
And I feel the same way.
And so I wanted to
use the experiences
I had as a person
with a disability that
has come from another
country, and there's probably
very few people like that
in Japan at the moment.
So I thought I should use
what I have to give back.
So that brought me to the
need for a lot of people face.
And I think it's
well-illustrated
with those stairs here.
Of course, it started
personal, when I just
wanted to go out with
friends or if I wanted
to go on vacation in
Japan, just the challenge
of finding the
right information.
Because you don't want to
go on a vacation and then
find out that you can't
get into your hotel,
because that would
be very traumatic.
So in doing a lot of research,
I was able to read Japanese now.
So I was looking at
things in Japanese.
I realized there still wasn't
much information in English
for people with disabilities.
And just as an
example here, you're
of course going to go to tourist
sites when you're coming here.
And if you look at
this website, you
look at the information
that's available in English,
it has very basic things
like the regular hours,
days closed-- which is
very useful information
for just your average visitor.
But you don't know
anything about if you're
in a wheelchair,
what's available.
If you go all the way
out there, are you
going to be able to
actually enjoy the place?
But if you look on
the Japanese site,
they have a lot of information.
For example, how far can
you go up to the castle, are
there wheelchairs
available for rent,
are there wheelchair toilets
available, where are they.
So all that
information is there,
but it's available
only in Japanese.
So for most people,
they're not going
to necessarily go and look
and translate the website,
because they figure, oh,
if it's not in English,
then there's nothing there.
So there's a real difference
between English and Japanese
versions of places.
As well for your
hotels, this website,
they have a universal twin.
And sort of another side
note is that the phrasing
in Japan and in North
America, or Europe,
or wherever, it is
quite different.
So a universal twin-- if
you said that to someone--
they'd have no idea what
you're talking about--
[LAUGHING]
--or a barrier free,
no way you would
know what that means in most
English speaking countries.
Most people would
search for accessible.
So even if it was written
in as barrier free,
that's not likely going
to click for somebody who
doesn't know the terminology.
And then again,
on the same site,
if you look at the
English page, the rooms
then have them list the
universal twin being available.
Now, there's probably
a practical reason
to this, and that they
can't use the booking
system to book accessible
rooms for the most part,
because they want to ensure that
it's people who actually have
disabilities that are using it.
So generally, you need to have
some sort of communication
with the hotel to
book your room.
And so maybe the
hotel made a decision
that don't have
enough English staff
to be able to handle
those requests.
Or they might have
come to the idea
that nobody in a wheelchair is
going to be coming and visiting
anyway, so there's no point
in translating this webpage as
well.
So I realize that there's
a lot of challenges
that people who want to come
just for a vacation have.
So that led me to the journey
of starting Accessible Japan.
I like this picture,
my mom took it.
I didn't know she took it.
And I wish she had a
better phone, though,
for better pictures.
So my mission statement
for Accessible Japan
is to provide as much
information as possible
on accessibility in Japan so
travelers with disabilities
can make informed decisions
based on their needs,
so they can enjoy
Japan to its fullest.
So the end result is I
want people to enjoy Japan.
I love Japan, that's
why I've moved here,
and that's why I want
to stay here forever.
And I want people to
enjoy Japan as well.
But a lot of people
with disabilities--
when they're looking
for places to go--
if there's not the
information there,
they don't want necessarily
spend all the money
to come over here if
they don't know what
they're going to come into.
So I try to get as much
information as possible.
And there are so many different
types of disabilities.
I can't say this
place is accessible,
or this place is not accessible,
because that's not something
I can decide for everybody.
So what I do is I try to
provide as much information as
possible, and then
they can make decisions
based on their own needs, and
whether they go to those places
or not.
So Accessible Japan has
been constantly pivoting
and updating and evolving.
I'd like to take credit for all
of the ideas, but a lot of them
come from just interacting with
people who have contacted me.
For example, I have a page
on bringing your guide
dog to Japan.
That's not something
I've ever considered.
But somebody asked
me a question,
well, what's the system like for
bringing a guide dog to Japan?
And because of that idea, that
part of the webpage was born.
So it's constantly
been changing.
At first, it was just
basic information
on how to get around,
maybe on a train,
or what it's like to
try to find a hotel,
or just sort of very general
ideas, as well as a blog.
And they use the blog to
introduce different parts
of Japan to people.
For example, how to
find a restaurant
if you have a wheelchair, or
even parts of Japanese culture.
So there's anime
there, A Silent Voice.
And the character from
that story, she's deaf.
So she has trouble
communicating.
And so that's sort of part
of the story in general
about human communication.
So somebody wrote
a review for that.
So I put that on there as well.
And then, of course, I have
a YouTube channel as well.
I use YouTube differently than
a lot of people use, in that I
look at people's
reviews of places
and don't really listen
to what they're saying.
But I'm constantly
looking at the ground
to see if there's steps or
if there's any barriers.
So because of that, I
realized, oh, I probably
should have some videos as well.
Because it speaks much more than
a few pictures or my comments.
So I try to provide as much
information in the videos
as well.
And again, going
back to the hotels,
I've created a searchable
database of hotels
with accessible rooms.
If you go to places like
Rakuten or other travel sites,
you have a little checkbox in
the extra information where
you can check off is
accessible or not.
But usually, that just says that
there is an accessible room.
It's still up to you to go
and research everything.
So I try to correlate all the
information I could get and put
it into the database.
So I got that either
through what information
is available on the websites,
or contacting the hotels
with surveys and asking,
as well as getting people
to put their own reviews on.
And a lot of the
things include toilets.
This will come up
a couple of times,
so I hope you're
used to toilets.
It's something
everybody needs to do.
And it's something
that's very important
if you're going to be spending
the money to stay at a place.
And in places like Europe
or in North America,
there are very strict
rules about what
an accessible room is like.
They have maybe what
angles the walls are at,
how you can approach the
toilet, how much space is
between the beds, et cetera.
And it's all very
well-dictated, so you can--
in general, with assurance--
rent a room, and you know
you're going to be OK.
Where in Japan, it tends to
be more general guidelines
of what's accessible.
So you can find two
hotels with a quote
unquote, "accessible rooms."
And one will have maybe some
handlebars next to the toilet.
And that's it.
And that's the only difference
from a regular room.
And other places will have
these huge sprawling rooms
with a toilet that's
covered in white towels
and looks like a hospital
with all these equipment
that you've never seen before.
So it can be quite a variety.
So I try to show that on the
reviews of the hotels as well.
Bathrooms-- of course, the
showers are difficult at times,
because people can't necessarily
get into the bathtub.
A lot of places in North America
will have a roll-in shower
so you can drive your wheelchair
right into the shower area.
But a lot of places in Japan--
very, very few have those.
So I had a little
life hack is that you
can see on the ground
there-- there's
actually a drain on the floor.
So as long as you
don't tell the staff,
you can put the chair next to
the bath tub and shower there.
As well as just information
on what the rooms look like.
So not all of them have
that kind of information,
but as much as I can get.
As well, of course,
people want to see things
when they come to Japan.
So I write reviews
of attractions.
Because I live in Tokyo,
most of the attractions
tend to be in Tokyo area.
But I have some others as well.
So they have general information
like a regular Japan guide
or whatever, would have some
background information-- how
to get there, what the
hours are, et cetera.
But I go into other
details as well.
For example, if they say
they have an elevator,
I try to try it out
and see what it's like.
So sure, on the website it
says there's an elevator,
but I wouldn't be able
to use this one by myself
because there's not enough
room to turn around or push
the buttons.
But again, that doesn't mean
that you can't go there,
just you should know
that in advance.
As well as maybe
for the gardens,
the routes that are available
for accessible travel.
Like this is Rikugien, I think.
And it has quite extensive
coverage of the grounds.
But some places, they
only have maybe about
a quarter of the place
is actually accessible.
So if you're going
to be going there,
you might not want to
intentionally go to that area.
And just little things
that may occur along
your path, such as these steps.
And, of course, toilets.
It is only one more mention
of toilets, so bear with me.
So yeah, when you're
going out, it's
an essential thing that most
people don't think about.
But if you're going
to be traveling around
and you need to use a
toilet in the pinch,
you want to know that
something's available.
So this helps people go
out and just sort of rest
assured that there
is something there.
And I don't need to
worry about it too much.
Next things I added, a general
glossary and phrasebook
for Japanese to English.
And again, that was
started because someone
asked me some questions--
how do you say this or this?
So I translated,
and I thought, oh, I
should put a page on that.
And actually, Lonely
Planet contacted me,
and they're going to
use this as the basis
for their accessible
travel guides.
And tourists.
I'm not a person
who likes tours.
Normally, I like to
go out on my own path.
But a number of people
were interested in tours.
And so I was able to work with
a couple of different companies
to consult on accessible
tours in Japan.
This company is called
Inside Japan Tours.
And they sort of offer
a complete package,
but there's a
couple of other ones
I work with that
have just day tours.
And so yeah, it
gives them a chance
to experience what it's like
to go around and give a tour.
So we went to a couple of
different tourist locations
in Tokyo.
We rode the train together.
Because it's one
thing just to sort
of read something on
the website, and this
is how it works, as opposed
to actually experience it.
And within a couple of months
of actually having this tour,
they had their first
disabled guest.
And so they're able to give
that person a tour around Japan
because of the consulting.
And I'm writing in Accessible
Japan wheelchair number one,
but this is number two
here on the screen.
A lot of people actually
request wheelchairs
or other medical
equipment in pinches.
For most people, they take
their wheelchair with them.
But there's been
times where I've
been contacted that somebody--
maybe they broke their leg two
weeks before their vacation.
I need to rent a wheelchair.
Or I'm going with my grandmother
and she can't walk very far.
Do you know a place I
can rent a wheelchair?
I don't want to buy one
just for coming to Japan.
So I tend to work
with rental companies
for providing most of those.
So I subcontracted them.
But yeah, if I'm in a
pinch, this one can fold up.
And it's in a bag, and I
can send it by takkyubin
to anywhere in the country
within a day or two.
And then, of course, people
want to take something with them
sometimes to carry
all their information.
And even if they have
a phone with them,
they don't want to use
the data or something
to search on the website.
So I made the Accessible
Japan travel guide for Tokyo.
And it's available right now,
if you want to buy it on iTunes.
And look at that,
it's got five stars.
And recently, I started
a forum for the website.
A lot of the interactions with
guests or with different people
have been very
important questions
that if you're just doing
email, it's sort of one-on-one.
And only people that are
involved in that email
can see the information.
But a lot of the
questions, I think,
could be very helpful
to other people as well.
So in a forum kind of
base, then it's searchable.
People can find it when
they're looking for things.
As well, if there's
something I want
to put some information on
that doesn't necessarily
require a full page, just
having a little bit of way
to add quick information
has been a big help.
And I've been growing steadily.
Compared to last
year, it's pretty much
doubled in access
just in the last year.
So that is very exciting,
except the more exciting thing
is communication with people
who are using the website.
And recently, I was contacted
by someone who said,
your site has
really encouraged me
to take my daughter to Japan.
She has cerebral palsy
and cannot walk very long
distances.
So she needs a wheelchair
to usually get around.
We're planning a
trip for next year.
And so when I talked
with this person,
his daughter loves anime.
So her dream is to go to
Akihabara and Nakano Broadway.
And so he was asking
about Nakano Broadway.
And actually, I'm not an anime
fan, so I never heard of it.
But I took the opportunity
to add that to the website.
So I went and did
a review of it.
But that was a real
encouragement to me,
because that's the whole
purpose of this website
is to encourage people to
come to Japan and enjoy it.
And to have someone actually
say that because of this, I
had the courage to
bring my daughter here.
So Accessible and Google have
a very strong relationship.
I think the first thing
is our shared goals.
And Google's, of course,
is to organize the world's
information and
make it universally
accessible and useful.
And I think that's a very common
goal that we have as well.
I'm sort of maybe a
microcosm of that,
in that I'm using very
niche information that not
a lot of people use,
but put it in one place,
and make it accessible
and useful to people.
In my day-to-day use,
of course, Google search
is probably the biggest
thing I use in a two way
kind of communication.
So people find Accessible
Japan through Google search.
Because of the nature of the
website being preparation
for traveling somewhere,
it tends that people only
use it until they go to Japan.
And then after that,
they don't really return.
So the majority of my
visitors are new visitors.
So through Google
Search, they're
able to find the website,
And then, for myself, because
I can't go to every place
that I need to go to or just
to answer random questions that
come up, I'm constantly
Googling things.
So I'm very, very, very
grateful for your work.
And you can definitely put me
at the top of the rankings,
if you want--
hint, hint.
Google Analytics is something
else I use quite frequently.
And I'm actually
slightly addicted to it.
I have it on my phone.
I'm quietly checking how
many visitors I get today.
But more importantly
it helps me to focus.
Through looking
at the statistics,
I can see, OK, well this area of
the website isn't very popular.
People aren't
using it very much.
But this area is
getting a lot of hits.
So people have definitely
interest in this area.
Because I have a
limited amount of time
that I can focus on this.
So I can put my effort
into places where
people can benefit the most.
Google Maps, of course,
is essential for the hotel
searches, as well as for me
for looking up information
and routes for people.
And, of course,
servers aren't free.
So Google Adsense helps
offset some of the costs
for running the website.
So I'm very thankful for that.
And then, just
sort of in closing,
I just wanted to have some
general disability and Google
working together, and
the essentials of that.
So I think it's important to
have a wide variety of input
on products.
So whether it's either
customers, or people
who are working for
the company, they
can have input to those things.
And you can find some
unexpected things.
You've heard probably many times
about somebody invented some
product that they thought was
going to go off and sell really
well, but it doesn't.
But then, they had some
unexpected use case for it.
And that ended up
turning into being
some huge, different,
world-changing idea.
So I encourage you to look
for unexpected use cases.
And a lot of people with
disabilities have them.
For example, Street View.
Most people maybe
would use it for when
they're driving to look
for, OK, I can turn here.
This is the landmark
I'm looking for.
Or probably the most amount of
people use Google and say, hey,
look, there's my house.
They get excited when
they see their car parked
in front or something, or
their dog or something.
For me, I use it all the time
to do quick accessibility spot
checks.
So if somebody asks
me a quick question,
I can go in, look at
it on Street View,
and I can give a rough idea
of what kind of barriers
they might face, if there's
steps or something like that.
I use it on my own
life as well, when
I'm looking for maybe like
a restaurant or something.
If there's no information
available on the website,
I can go to Street View
and I can see, oh, oh,
that's in the basement.
I can't get in there.
Or oh, it's on the first floor.
I can get in no problem and not
need to worry about it anymore.
Remote desktop, as
I mentioned before,
I have my helpers help me.
And when I get into bed, I'm not
necessarily ready to sleep yet,
and I still have some
things I want to do.
But because of the
schedules, it's firm.
I can use Google Chrome
remote desktop for my phone
to keep working on my computer.
So that's an unexpected
thing, I think, probably
for most people.
And I think a big
thing coming up
is Google Home and
the smart speaker,
and IoT devices in general.
I think it's going to be a very
big game-changer for people
with disabilities.
Most of the commercials--
except-- are
about families getting up
in the morning and saying,
hey, turn on the TV.
And everybody gets
excited about that.
But I think more
important is that somebody
who can't move and can't use
their arms and legs very well
can use that.
And they can live a
more fulfilling life
without as much need for
other people to help them out.
I've dropped the remote control
on on my TV at times when
there's been no helper around.
And I can't pick it up.
And thanks to my Chromecast, I
can watch something else on TV
without having to
worry about that.
So look for those
unexpected use cases.
And since I have your
undivided attention,
I brought a dream list with
me for some Google products,
and mostly Maps, I think--
because that has the biggest
impact for a lot of people's
lives, or at least for mine,
anyways.
Accessible exits.
Right now, I think
on Maps, it will
show you where the exits are
for train stations and subways,
but not necessarily which
one has the elevator at it.
And I spend numerous minutes
of my day trying to find
which place has an actual exit.
And that doesn't
come up sometimes.
And if it had that,
that could really
make things a lot easier
and smooth for transfers,
or just going out and about.
As well as toilets.
This is the last
time, I promise.
There was an app that I used
to use called Check A Toilet.
It's a Japanese sort of
crowdsourced application.
And so people would
use the Maps API,
and they'd put
pins down for where
there were accessible toilets.
And they could share pictures
and information on them.
But because nobody's
really been updating it,
it's been depreciated.
So you can't actually
use it anymore.
So if it could be included
into Google Maps somehow,
where the nearest toilets are.
Because that could help
a lot of people, I think.
That was the last
toilet thing, I promise.
Inaccessible route
option as well.
Right now, you can choose
things like minimize transfers
or minimize walking distance.
If there is an option
for accessible route,
a number of times, if you
choose the walking path and you
come to a busy
street, it'll go over
the bridge to cross the street.
And that's the path that
you're usually shown.
But, of course, that
doesn't work for me.
So sometimes, I'm
following the map,
and all of a sudden, uh-oh.
There's a bunch of steps.
I can't get over
to the other side.
So having some sort
of accessible route
would be fantastic.
Accessible hotel rooms,
whether they have them or not.
When you search in Maps,
you choose a hotel.
And on the left hand
side, it will show you,
for example, what
the price range is
or the website, the
phone number, et cetera.
And lately, thank you
very much for adding
accessible stations on for the
train stations, I noticed that.
If you have the same thing
for accessible hotels,
so if it had just
an extra line that
said accessible room
available, yes or no,
that could definitely help a lot
of people searching for hotels.
And indoor mapping,
of course, I'm
sure that's something
Google's working on
and could help for finding your
way around finding elevators
instead of the stairs.
Because a lot of those
elevators are buried way deep
into different areas.
And maybe possibly bug
bounties for accessibility.
I'm not sure if you
know, but in Japan, there
are a lot of places
called workshops.
So for people with
different disabilities
that can't get regular
jobs, maybe they
work in these special
workshops where they'll maybe
sort bottle caps or
they'll put chopsticks
into the holders, et cetera.
And it's sort of a
way to have people
with intellectual
disabilities have a job.
If they could maybe
team up with Google,
it could be a good
CSR opportunity
to maybe go and check
the information that's
been added to the
local guides about
whether a place is
accessible or not.
And finally, it's remember that
accessibility benefits many.
Everybody maybe thinks
that, oh, well it's
for a certain group of people.
But if we all live long
enough, everybody's
going to become
disabled in some way--
whether it's your eyesight gets
poorer, or your knees go out
and you can't walk as far.
So I think is should be thought
of not as special money used
on this group, but as opposed
to investment in your future.
And that's why accessibility
is very important.
Today, I was on the way and
I transferred at Morista.
And in front of me
in the elevator,
there's an elderly couple.
And there's a couple of
mothers with baby strollers.
And there's people
with injuries.
And those people
are all using things
that were quote
unquote, "designed"
for people with disabilities.
So it's important to
remember that accessibility
is for everyone.
It's also for the person
delivering packaging.
They also appreciate the
slopes and the elevators.
And then finally, a
real dream request
is I know that you
guys are trying to get
as much information on mapping.
So if you need another
Google car, let me know.
You can strap it on the
back of my wheelchair.
And I will gladly go
wherever you want me to.
All right, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]